following tristan thompson's recent
paternity news a source tells e.t his ex
khloe kardashian is quote really hurt
i'm gonna figure it all out i promise
you after being named as the subject of
a paternity lawsuit with marley nichols
tristan later revealed following a
paternity test that he is the father of
marley's son who was born in december he
also shared this public apology on
instagram writing in part quote chloe
you don't deserve this you don't deserve
the heartache and humiliation i have
caused you you don't deserve the way i
have treated you over the years now a
source tells et that the 37 year old
good american founder is quote really
hurt and saddened by tristan's actions
and that public apology well e.t source
says it isn't helping quote this has
been a tough pill for her to swallow and
she does feel unsettled and pretty
crushed
of course chloe and tristan share a
three-year-old daughter true and have
had an on and off romance since 2016
which includes several cheating
allegations against the nba star
including the most recent one with
marlee prior to tristan's paternity news
et soar says chloe and tristan were in a
good place and had plans to move in
together
tristan has since pulled out of escrow
on his house in encino that he was in
the process of selling and is no longer
moving in with chloe a source previously
told et the reality star is feeling
quote pretty embarrassed about the news
adding that while she's always so
positive this quote brought her down a
little i just want to live my life and
be happy
she has always been into giving tristan
tons of chances and deep down held out
hope that they would maybe get back
together one day there is no hope and
it's really done for now but she thinks
it's for the best the source says that
while this isn't the ending coco wanted
with a pro athlete she is grateful to
have her three-year-old daughter and
just wants to move on i
think to be happy that comes from within
something she told et when they first
split back in 2019 following his
cheating scandal with kylie jenner's
former bestie jordan woods you know
things happen and of course i'm sorry
and apologetic as much as i can be i'm
just super happy and content and i'm
focused on work and like taking care of
me my body and soul and true and i just
i'm having so much fun with her and all
that echoes what a source recently told
et after describing her relationship
with tristan as quote strained working
on your personal growth internally is
something that will be a forever
um mission and i always want to evolve
and grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people quote chloe has been spending
time with her sisters and family working
out eating healthy and focusing on her
mind body and soul she's getting back on
her a-game
[Music]
you